ليست من عاده رجال الفضاء التخلي عن
طموحاتهم بسهوله اذا ماذا يدور في عقله
غير الارتجال والتسرع وفكره تويتر الازرق
التي لا تحقق اراده قويه بل وتنفر
المعلمين هناك فكره اخرى اقترحها ماسك في
كواليس الاجتماع الاول قال والروايه على
عهده موقع ايديبرج الامريكي لماذا لا
ندعوا اكبر صنع المحتوى على يوتيوب
لمنصتنا ونفع لهم 10% اكثر
فماذا يحدث اذا نجحت الفكره قد يتحول
تويتر الى اكبر منافس لليوتيوب واحده من
انجح منصات الحاليه لعبد الفيديوهات جديه
ماسك بهذه بهذا الشان ظهرت قبل اسبوع
محادثه علنيه على تويتر بينهم وبين واحدا
من اهم صانعي المحتوى على يوتيوب مستر بست
المحماسك لا هو ان تويتر يدرس رفع عائدته
اراده الفيديو من المشاهده ماذا يعني ذلك
باللغه عالم الصانعي المحتوى يعني
الملايين لكن كيف صناعه المحتوى الكبار في
يوتيوب يكسبون تقريبا 17 جنيه استرلينيا
مشاهده لانه هو فيديو واحد من فيديوهات
مستر بن يكسب الرجل خمسه ملايين اجنيه
300 مليون مشاهده مثلا
نعم هذا صحيح خمسه ملايين للفيديو الواحد
واذا كسر ماسك هذه الحسبه التي تعد من بين
الاعلى في السوق ورفعها فلا شك ان عالم
وسائل التواصل سيشهدوا هجره افتراضيه
تاريخيه
افكار وماسك لا تنتهي لديه فكره اخرى لكن
هذه المره في جبهه الصراع اخرى
باعلان مالك تويتر الجديد قالوا الماسك
استعداده لخوض حرب مع شركه ابل بدل دفع
رسوم لها لتحميل التطبيقي من متجر اب ستور
التي تصل الى 30% ينضم تويتر الى حرب
موجوده
شكاوى ضد الاحتكار ضد ابل في اوروبا في ما
رفعت جيمز دعوه قضائيه ضدها في الولايات
المتحده عام 2020 وفي مؤشر على هذا الحلف
الثلاثي المحتمل اعاد المديران التنفيذيان
للشركاتتين جيمز وصفات تغريدات مصر
المتعلقه بابستور والرسوم